et mon idée effectivement c'était de
proposer ce qui a été votée au dernier
conseil municipal la taxe sur les
friches commerciales donc sur les locaux
vacants
pourquoi parce que ça ne bénéficie pas
aux commerces à côté si à une
discontinuité aux touristes aux
riverains
et puis en plus si ces vacances pendant
des années c'est qu'il ya une raison
c'est quand on veut vendre une maison
dans les tours à la bande mais une
question de prix et une question de
trouver la bonne personne donc pareil
pour un local donc aujourd'hui je suis
parti sur le maximum c'est là que j'ai
doublé les taux minimum donc aujourd'hui
ceva 30 ou 40% sur première deuxième
troisième année sur une liste qu'on
propose l'administration fiscale c'est
qui est intéressant c'est que je suis
pas je suis pas dans une optique de te
taper sur tout le monde avec le bâton je
suis plutôt dans une optique de faire
des réactions mais un certain nombre de
bail ont déjà pris contact avec moi j'ai
rencontrés m'ont donné d'explications
faut qu'ils avancent et puis si a une
bonne raison pour laquelle locaux sont
pas le web elles peuvent être exonérés
de cette surtaxe
mais ma première idée c'est aussi de
motiver ceux qui se désintéressent il ya
des gros propriétaires qui ne vivent pas
là qui se dit c'est pas grave si c'est
pas loin c'est pas admissible pour les
autres